puede parecer cualquier otro los
campamentos a lo largo del valle de la
bekáa pero este a diferencia de los
otros está dirigido por una mujer maneja
baja bebe tajo doctor es 'una shauis
como se le conoce a quien gobierna en
los campamentos una figura
tradicionalmente masculina pero con la
profunda crisis económica acataría se al
líbano los roles están cambiando
ahora las familias se alimentan
básicamente de pan no tenemos mucho más
las mujeres refugiadas han empezado a
trabajar fuera del ámbito del hogar y
hemos demostrado que podemos hacer mucho
más que cuidar a nuestros hijos jim se
encarga de toda la logística y la
gestión para el funcionamiento en los
campamentos de que se cumplan las
medidas sanitarias para prevención de la
comida y de escuchar las necesidades de
la comunidad nos toma al buffet 6
anicama 8 cuando vieron que toda la
comunidad estaba contenta conmigo que me
gustaba mi trabajo mi marido y mi hijo
mayor empezaron a apoyarme también ahora
dirijo tres campamentos de teleatlas
muhammad las dificultades económicas han
empujado a más mujeres del campamento a
asumir responsabilidades y liderazgo
fuera del núcleo familiar
no es un trabajo fácil para ellas ante
la falta de confianza en sí mismas en
una sociedad acostumbrada a la autoridad
del hombre los hombres no estaban bien
como trabajadores humanitarios estamos
apoyando distintas actividades para el
empoderamiento de la mujer y así romper
ese círculo vicioso de pobreza y dominio
patriarcal en los campamentos en visas
la ayuda fue baja también es una shauis
y en su campamento está motivando atrás
refugiadas para que aprendan a leer ya
escribir
ya las chicas tienen que casarse y ya
está nada de estudiar aquí nos sentimos
más independientes cuantas más
refugiadas sepamos leer y escribir más
útiles seremos para la comunidad based
on your way tiene baja han roto las
barreras de género una sociedad comparte
al call como la silla
estas mujeres inspiran a las nuevas
generaciones a seguir sus pasos y
contribuir a la igualdad entre hombres y
mujeres en el futuro de siglo